hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on a foreign again and
today we have a little bit of an
interesting video today we're continuing
the series and talking about the lore of
the characters within for honor and
we've been starting to do this a lot
with year three and today we're gonna be
talking about the newest character soon
da fool hall which is the male and
female variation respectively or the
actual in-game name which is it sounds
like zan who but I actually believe it's
pronounced Jean who Ori alive but with a
J as always with this stuff do keep in
mind I'm not a historian alright I don't
know every single bit of detail so if I
happen to get something wrong let me
know in the comments below or if I left
something out that maybe you know that
it's kind of an interesting detail
towards the character also let me know
in the comments below so real quick a
description of the Jean who is that they
excel at following up their dodges with
quick attacks relying on their mobility
and long single edge chunda blade to
outmaneuver their opponents as masters
of artillery they bring devastating new
feats to the battlefield they wield a
weapon called the Chung doll which is a
single bladed Chinese great sword that
requires great skill and patience to
wield with devastating strikes now I'm
pretty sure this description actually
comes straight from Ubisoft and
obviously they're gonna get this you
know they're gonna nail it on the head
and that's pretty much what this
character is all about Jean who roughly
translates to slaying tiger or war tiger
so if you want to end up using that
phrase you totally can a quick google
search of the character name is going to
reward you with a bunch of searches
relating to the game so obviously this
means that this specific name isn't
actually a historical name it could be
someone else's name which of course how
they got it they seem to be based off
some type of group called the jinnee Wei
Jin wei jin yi wei something like that
basically they're also called the
embroidered uniform guard which i'm just
gonna call eug throughout the rest of
this video they were essentially a
Imperial secret police with the
Emperor's of the Ming Dynasty within
China just in case you're not caught up
with your history especially within the
Chinese culture there was a bunch of
different dynasties like the Ching
dynasty the Ming Dynasty and a bunch of
different ones that let up and it all
had to do with who was in power and who
the Emperor was at the time as a secret
police though they had authority to
overrule judicial proceedings in
prosecutions with full control over the
arrest interrogation and punishment of
an
including other nobles and imperial
family members they were also tasked
with collecting military intelligence
and partaking in battle planning the eug
were actually hand-picked from the
military and brought up as children
receiving special martial arts training
on top of wielding swords made of a
special type of steel as I said the
jinnee way used to call themselves the
embroidered uniformed guard and they
were founded around 1368 by the Hong Wu
emperor as personal bodyguards to defend
him against the opposing warlord Chen
Yuliang after that fight the Emperor
founded the Ming Dynasty and then became
Emperor I know it sounds confusing I was
saying that he was called Emperor even
though he wasn't they just didn't
display a specific name so just know
that before he wasn't considered Emperor
now he is considered Emperor and now
this is the Ming Dynasty one of the
first things that the Emperor did right
away was send spies to gain intelligence
on his questionably loyal subjects the
organization actually started with
around 500 members and then quickly grew
to about 14,000 in just under 3 years
the Emperor had actually reduced their
duties a bit since the group is actually
abusing power seeing as they were
gaining so many numbers every single
month or so and one of the main reasons
was because they actually ended up
killing 40,000 people essentially in in
1393 the Emperor had like I said reduced
the authority on the Yugi because of
their investigation on a rebellion plot
by a man called lan yu in which about
40,000 people were implicated and
executed because of treason basically
the whole group thought that he was you
know targeted for treason
obviously this may or may not have been
the case regardless of the situation lan
yu ended up being slaughtered as well as
all of his people and that was equated
to about 40,000 the group was eventually
disbanded in 1644 when the Ming Dynasty
actually came to an end by rebel forces
and that is actually the same day that
the Ching dynasty started so basically
what we can kind of infer here is that
if it wasn't for the rebels overthrowing
the Ming Dynasty in 1644 that the eug
would have definitely kept going into
the later years the headquarters of the
barracks was roughly around west of
Tiananmen Square which is where the
Great Hall of the People is currently
located in present time so roughly
around there and also that the default
hat these on who wears that very black
looking this oval shape hat is actually
in there is it which is part of their
default outfit that
called a futo and normal citizens were
actually not allowed to wear these only
the high-ranking officers but the normal
people could wear them if they were
attending a wedding or a special event
involving a noble or an imperial family
members so they couldn't wear it on
their day to day for the specific lore
about the characters the male and female
versions straight from ubisoft
themselves we're gonna start with the
soon dot which is the male variation
essentially the way that they tried to
craft this story is that soon da had a
basically betrayed his family for power
his family and the Emperor were at this
very small family war of course the
Emperor being the Emperor having so much
power and soon da just being a family he
of course ended up losing and he was
basically stuck with two choices he can
either die with his family or serve the
Emperor but if he had to serve the
Emperor he had to kill his family in
front of him to prove his loyalty and he
elected to kill his family and he's
still serving the emperor to this day
the female name is actually called foo
ho and she had loads of different skills
that she had learned during her
childhood and up in her teenage years
and it actually caught wind of the
Empress of the of where she lived and
but the problem was that her hometown
was being invaded and they decided that
she needed to up her skill a little bit
so she ended up joining the Empress to
defend and wanted more of a challenge
according to the developers they said
that we would learn a lot more during
the season most likely through the
arcade quest descriptions and seasonal
event about the character about why all
of a sudden that they happen to join the
Wulin in the fight because they could
have came in the very beginning but all
of a sudden they just come up now like
what's the reason like why now I'm not
like yesterday or some [ __ ] so we're
gonna figure that out definitely during
the seasonal event about why the
characters came when they decided to
there really isn't much about the Chun
now other than what I said in the
beginning that it was a single bladed
two-handed Chinese great sword and it
was actually used a lot during the Ming
Dynasty it didn't start during the Ming
Dynasty but it was used a lot more
commonly and within this dynasty right
around the time that the group was
formed and of course right around the
same time that our characters Phu ho and
son da would be present which is why
they wield that sword and funny you know
I actually found this from reddit but I
had pretty damn funny I for some odd
reason actually soon got kind of reminds
me of the Asian announcer guy from Iron
Chef here's a picture from reddit to
show you about that and it's not even
wrong either it's kind of
thing if you know what Iron Chef is you
definitely the real one for that yeah
and that's basically kind of a quick
video on what the characters are their
specific stories being the male in FEMA
variations as well as just who the
overall character is in game that we're
gonna be playing and kind of who they're
loosely based off of as I stated before
I'm not a historian so I may have got
something wrong or I may have forgot to
add something that maybe you thought it
would be very critical to the video so
if any of those happen to come up while
you're watching this video definitely be
sure to leave a comment and I'll let you
know and I'll maybe add it to a pin
comment at the bottom cuz I actually
want everyone to know kind of the whole
story about this character because it
seems very intriguing what that guys
like the video if you do enjoy subscribe
if you're new I cover the informational
side a foreigner that being the balance
changes the hero updates the patch notes
and the leaks if when we kept up today
with everything happening within the
world of Warner and never miss out on an
update definitely stay subscribe the
channel guys take care of grace today
enjoy
[Music]